The Star Wars film series is one of the most
commercially and critically successful franchises
in history.
Ticket sales alone have yielded over $9.5
billion worldwide to date — and that's not
counting merch sales, licensing deals, and
other profits.
Since its start in 1977, the series has grown
from a trilogy of well-received fantasy movies
into a full-blown, worldwide institution,
applauded for its ability to excite and inspire
audiences.
Of course, this isn't to say that the Star
Wars franchise is completely perfect.
Far from it.
Fans can, and will, pick apart the movies
and find dozens of slip-ups and make a laundry
list of less-than-awesome moments that slightly
mar the overall pictures.
But those little moments would be small potatoes
in comparison to the mistake Disney has admitted
to making with the Star Wars franchise — one
that the studio is trying to remedy as we
speak.
During a September 2018 interview with The
Hollywood Reporter, Walt Disney Company CEO
Bob Iger addressed the fact that, after acquiring
Lucasfilm for just over $4 billion in 2012,
Disney has churned out one Star Wars movie
every year since 2015.
Specifically, those movies would be J.J. Abrams'
Episode 7: The Force Awakens, the series-first
anthology film Rogue One in 2016, the Rian
Johnson-directed Episode 8: The Last Jedi
in December 2017, and the "young Han Solo"
movie, simply called Solo, just five months
later in May 2018.
When reporter Matthew Belloni brought up the
seemingly growing impression that Disney should
pump the brakes on its Star Wars releases,
and not put out a new movie each year, Iger
surprisingly agreed.
He actually admitted that the huge volume
of releases right out of the gate was a total
mistake, and even took personal responsibility
for the evident, fatigue-inducing misstep.
Iger confessed,
"As I look back, I think the mistake that
I made — I take the blame — was a little
too much, too fast."
Looking ahead, the CEO said that Disney will
no longer be producing Star Wars movies at
such an accelerated pace.
According to Iger, fans "can expect some slowdown"
following the release of JJ Abrams' Episode
9 — although no one should expect the House
of Mouse to bring things to a total halt.
As Iger explained, the state of Star Wars
movies beyond 2019's Episode 9 will still
be robust — just with a little more breathing
room.
He reminded readers that Game of Thrones directors
David Benioff and D.B. Weiss are actively
developing their own Star Wars saga, about
which very little is currently known.
Last we heard, Rian Johnson was still tinkering
away with development on his own film trilogy.
The company is also developing at least one
big-budget TV show for its upcoming streaming
service.
But this content, Iger said, will be served
up a little more judiciously, with the company
being, quote, "a little bit more careful about
volume and timing."
The suggestion that Disney should throttle
down on the Star Wars movies isn't a particularly
new idea.
Fans and commentators have been talking about
the potential consequences of Star Wars oversaturation
for a while, with the once-unthinkable term
"Star Wars fatigue" becoming a frequent talking
point.
The franchise took a major hit with the massively
underperforming Solo: A Star Wars Story, which
essentially bombed at the box office after
a notoriously troubled production.
Following that high-profile disappointment,
a whole lot of people got on board with the
idea that Disney's strategy for Star Wars
was actually killing interest in the once-venerable
franchise.
The common wisdom was that Lucasfilm was trying
too hard to mimic the release calendar of
Marvel Studios, and it's backfiring in a big
way.
While there are fans and viewers who are perfectly
happy with the current state of Star Wars,
there's a vocal segment of the fanbase that's
all-but-begging for Disney to get its act
together as the series wraps up the Skywalker
Saga and moves on to stories beyond.
Iger's comments seem to suggest that those
fans are finally being heard.
Though it's refreshing to hear Iger straight-up
admitting Disney dropped the ball, is it possible
that the damage is already done?
That's hard to predict.
Already, some feel that Disney has bigger
problems with its Star Wars approach than
the high volume of releases.
After the interview, THR writer Graeme McMillan
questioned whether "volume and timing are
really to blame," and suggested that perhaps
the audience has a problem with these specific
Star Wars movies.
In other words, a lot of people might just
dislike the stories that Disney's telling
— and that's a harder problem to fix than
just stretching out a release schedule.
Still, it seems that the people in charge
at Disney are doing some serious reflection
about how they might have mangled their very
expensive space fantasy series.
A less-dense release schedule is a good start.
As to whether or not that will be enough to
bring the magic back to Star Wars, that remains
to be seen.